in battle shown in anime there are
tropes you know how it's almost always
the main hero fighting the main villain
and fate will bend backwards all the way
to make sure that will happen there's
also the designated girl fight because a
lot of times it's the female members of
the good guys team and the villains who
would inevitably end up fighting i think
that those tropes need no introduction
for you but here's something that i've
noticed and it's gonna be our topic for
today's special video it's the
father-son duel with shonen anime's
insanely large cast of characters the
long run and the inevitable clash of
ideals it's not too uncommon to have a
key battle in the series be one
featuring a father-son duo at times it
comes out as a grudge match while other
times it comes out as part of a training
session today we're going over eight of
the most notable father versus sun
moments in anime but before we get
started i'm here to urge you to hit that
like and subscribe button
[Music]
it seems that bleach just doesn't have
the father-son duos with the best
relationships while i wouldn't consider
ichigo in ishian's relationship to be
full of tension besides the bickering
the same can't be said of uru and ryuken
the two quinces just don't get along too
well and then have a heartfelt duel
early on in the aranka arc this battle
features a de-powered uryu trying his
hardest to just defeat his father
through his wits give this guy some
respect even without his quincy powers
due to the events of the soul society
arc uryu still manages to come up with
some creative ways to try and beat his
father ultimately i still consider the
battle a win for ryuken who manages to
defeat his son by overcoming all those
tricks i just mentioned only to reveal
that it's all an elaborate training arc
of sorts in the end despite their less
than stellar relationship ryukan had
intended to restore his son's powers by
taking the latter to the limit
before we continue i'd like to give a
shout out to the sponsors of this video
alchemy stars alchemy stars is a hero
collector game that takes you to the
beautiful world of aurora a realm where
science and magic cross having spent
some time on the game i'd say that i
immediately fell in love with the art
the character designs are my jam and
there's nothing more addictive than
having these heroes join your ranks and
growing stronger along with them even
though i'm not rolling for units and
collecting my favorites i'd like to
bring your attention to the unique grid
based gameplay of alchemy stars here let
me give you a demo of the strategic
intricacies that goes into every battle
in this game this isn't your typical
grid based strategy game as you need to
bring your a-game every time to win the
battles in the grandest way possible
take advantage of those coloured tiles
in order to lead your team to unleash
destruction upon your foes as more
stages open up you'll have to learn not
to only optimize your units and attack
chains but also deal with various stage
gimmicks and hazards that hamper your
quest the game is set for release this
summer it won't be long now and i hope
that i can see you in the fields of
aurora soon i can help you get started
with a link in my description box so
what are you waiting for check the link
in the description and download now
let's take a look at one piece now shall
we specifically sanji vs judge not too
long ago in one piece standards we've
got another epic father-son battle to
add to the gauntlet with sanji finally
getting his hands on his father who he's
not on good terms with and that's
putting it lightly sanji hates his
neglectful and abusive father and that
all comes to a boiling point when they
finally battle each other the two had a
back and forth duel after sanji
reaffirms his convictions empowered by
unpleasant memories of his youth sanji
manages a furious recovery however he
gets caught off guard by his father's
soldiers and that's what leads to his
defeat from a storyline perspective it
would make sense at that point of the
story but i personally want to see him
break through those walls soon i think
that eventually we could potentially see
him overcome that final hurdle and
complete his character arc
[Music]
since we're on the topic of classic
anime let's continue with yusuke versus
ryzen among the numerous arcs of yuu
hakusho the three kings arc is one of
the less renowned ones and that doesn't
mean that it's devoid of some key
moments and memorable fights however one
such fight is the battle between yusuke
and his ancestral father ryzen after the
appetizer of a battle yusuke and his
team go on to meet ryzen for their
battle it could have been a mistake on
yusuke's part as he gets absolutely
trounced in this battle despite all that
yusuke's been through in terms of
becoming stronger he still realizes that
his father's strength far surpasses his
despite the father not even being in
peak form this pushes yusuke into a
training arc only to be disappointed
when it's time for the rematch despite
ryzen nearly killing yusuke in their
second meeting the former simply
explained some important revelations to
his son before shortly dying due to
starvation yet such a shame we never got
to see the fight between father and son
when they're at their peak powers now
isn't it then again who are we kidding
ryzen's probably going to run away with
it considering how pig ryzen is and is
probably the strongest being in the yu
yu hakusho universe
we move on from that one to the next
battle gara versus rasa the battle of
sand wielders is one of the early
highlights in naruto's fourth shinobi
war reincarnated by garbudo rasa gets
sent to fight the allied shinobi forces
it's just fitting that his major
bachelor would be in the form of a duel
with his own son gaara and rasa was just
a thing of beauty and a great battle
between two sandbenders so to speak it's
a battle that makes it seem that the
father is in control throughout and he
moves on to finish the job with the
techniques he's used to defeat the one
tail however though to his surprise he
realizes too late that his son is no
longer who he once was realizing some
regrets as a parent rasa finally
succumbs and gets resealed after a
climactic scene but before doing so
however he gets to share a very tender
moment with his son where he
congratulates the latter and expresses
his apologies
[Music]
next in line is goku vs gohan
how could we not include probably the
most iconic father-son duo in anime goku
and gohan had a lot of history and my
favorite among those moments besides the
passing of the torch way back in the
cell saga is the dragon ball super fight
in a bid to become stronger gohan passes
on more training with piccolo in order
to have a more challenging test a tag
fight just doesn't do it so gohan
proposes an all-out battle against his
father goku in super saiyan 2 is already
a humongous challenge to have in front
of you but gohan just knows no backing
down and still manages to keep pace this
forces goku to bring out super saiyan
blue which gohan responds to by powering
up even more at the end of the clash
goku reigns supreme but gohan more than
earned some newfound respect from his
father i think the fight with its
responses of power-ups and display of
sheer destruction helps encapsulate why
a lot of people love dragon ball so much
the cool thing about the fight is that
it's not just a battle of strength it's
gohan's attempt to showing the fruits of
his growth and the reaffirmation of his
vow to keep pushing himself and his
father to greater heights among the
father-son fights in anime i think the
few can come close to the emotional
stakes of gray versus silver
it's been a long time coming and with
the culmination of fairy tale at hand
it's only right for gray to finally have
his long fated showdown against his
father who's long believed to be dead
it's the battle of two top tier ice
wielders in fairy tale and it's just
full of hype i know fairy tales been
notorious for some of its fights but i
think that the fight between gray and
silva is one that didn't disappoint as
expected from two people who know each
other's moves very well the fight ended
up being touch and go with both fighters
countering each other's moves silver
gets the upper hand for a stretch but
powered by his resolve and memories of
the past gray wins after some clever
bluffing in the technique vambrace i
like this fight because it feels like
the culmination of grey's backstory that
started all the way to the second arc of
the series it camps off a long journey
on a plot point that i honestly think
that the author had forgotten but we did
get some closure and some feels along
the way
[Music]
history stems from way back they've
never been each other's best friends
ever since the time kamui was much
younger and it all came ahead towards
the end of the rakuyo decisive battle
arc the sudden appearance of kamui
sparks a battle between father and son
and you can just feel all the pent-up
emotions overflow with each move they do
for kamui it's a battle of redemption a
way for him to prove that he's come a
long way and has become far stronger
than his father could imagine the fight
was looking like something that would
end when one of the two die but gagura
manages to stop the battle and appeal to
their familial bonds
so that's it for today pretty much a
video befitting the occasion of father's
day everyone if you're up for more
special videos like this please comment
with your suggestions otherwise feel
free to talk about other stuff like your
favorite father-son duos in anime if you
enjoyed the video which i sure hope you
did don't forget to drop a like and
maybe share the video and the channel to
your friends you may also support the
channel through the patreon link that
i'll be putting in the description box
and if you want to support the channel
further channel memberships are open too
unlocking new videos that you might have
missed out from way back don't forget to
check out the sponsors of this video
alchemy stars the links in the
description i'll end with that for now
and i hope to see you again next time
[Music]
[Music]
you